اليوم راح احكي لكم
اول مره اسمع بيها مصطلح
الحاضنه كان قبل حوالي 22 سنه
كم
يعني
[موسيقى]
الاطفال الحديثي الولاده
وتتوفر لهم البيئه المناسبه للنمو ضعيفين
بس بالعمل ببيئه العمل ان كبيتارز كان
مصطلح جديد
وصار كم مبادره تشجيعيه بالشركه يشتغل بها
قبل 22 سنه
انه تشجع الموظفين والكادر اللي عنده اي
افكار جديده لمنتجات جديده او خدمات جديده
انه
يشاركها وياه الشركه والشركه تحتاجنا
وتوفر للبيئه وكل الاحتياجات اللي يحتاجها
على مده يطلق المنتوج مالته او
الخدمات مؤته
دارك الايام
صار عندنا تغيير جذري بالعراق بال 2003
لما تغير النظام
الديكتاتورين
من الحريه
2003 بدايه 2004
صناعيه افكار صناعيه
هندسيه حتى اهميه مشاري
المواهب العراقيه الشابه
والشباب الاذكياء المهندسين
واخذنا مشاري
وبدينا نشتغل
شغل مجاني متميز معروف جوده عاليه الفريق
ماله العمل والكاذ تشانوب جدا متعاونين
الشغل مالتنا كنا نفتخر به
بال 2010
تغييرات بالتشريعات بالعراق اللي هي قانون
الاستثمار طلع طلعت تعليمات وافاءات
وتسهيلات على تجذب
العراقيين او الراس مال العراقي اللي خارج
العراق الى داخل البلد وانه تتكون بمشاريع
وافكار طبعا اكيد ال ال الراس مال الاجنبي
بريك الفتره
قررنا ان هنا ندخل بالاستثمار وفعلا اخذنا
فد مساحه ارض كبيره بالبصره
وقلنا انه نسوي بيها فد مشروع بهاء الارض
يكون
صناعي لوجستي تعاونيه كبيره بحيث انه
نطلق خدمات
متعدده
سوق بس مواجهتنا مشاكل هوايه بس اهم مشاكل
هوايه وتاخيرات وهوايه اهم اهم مشكله هي
او عقم واجهتها هي البيروقراطيه
البيروقراطيه العراقيه
ماكو اي بيروقراطيه بالعالم تشبه
البرقوقراطيه مالتنا البيروقراطيه مالتنا
مختلفه
وطبعا هي صارت او نشات
لانه
القوانين والتعليمات وسياقات الاداريه
اللي كانت ما قبل 2003
الفترات القديمه
اصطدمت ويا التعليمات والقوانين الجديده
اللي طلعت
لاحقا بعد التغيير
المعاملات والرخص
وكل الامور الاداريه صار بيها نوع من
التاخير
الموظفين بالدوله
الدخله
[موسيقى]
الارتباك
لانه سوني فسر هذا القانون اكو فد منطقه
رماديه كنت تصادم بانهاء القوانين بيناتها
اكو سياقات جديده طلعت وياها التعليمات
الجديده
فنشا عندك
تاخير قوي
نسوي لجنه
ناخذ بيار رايي
نستفسر من
الكتاب هناك كتابكم
كل دائره لها لها فتفت
سياقاتها المختلفه من ولي وقع من ولي يهمش
هوسات
الرسميه
والايفادات والزحمه مالت المعاملاتكم
والبريد
اي معامله
قامت ما تاخذ بالها شهر او شهرين او ثلاثه
سنين تدخل انت الدوامه
من بايدينا بهذا المشروع مالتنا
صار عندنا تاخير كلش قوي السؤال اللي
طرحناه
المهم جوهري
شلون نقدر
نتجوز
البيروقراطيه اني ما اقدر اني كان انسان
ما اقدر احل هذه
بس شلون اقدر اتفاداها شلون اقدر اتجاوزها
طبعا التذمر
الانتقاد ما يفيد لانه لما تنتقد او تدمر
راح يقولوا لك يابا معاملتك بعد تمشي حسب
الاصول والضوابط وسياقات الاداريه
القانونيه ايش بك انت اوكي على شو قاعده
تشتكي ييه هاي ماخذهم جراحه وقعدت تمشي به
سلاسل بهذا هو احنا يعني لازم نسوي شغل
على سياقات
ال- ال- الحل شنو
الفكره ال ال ال ال اللي اللي
وصلنا لها هي انه طبعا دائما يقول لك
الحاجه هي امه الاختراع
فالفكره اللي وصلنا لها اللي نقدر انه
نجاوز بيرفقراطيه هي انه نخلق
المعجلات الصناعيه
المعجنات الصناعيه بمن طبعا
تعديل او تطوير لفكره الحاضنات اللي حكيت
عليها بالبدايه
طبعا انت تبدي اول شيء
بمجتمع خلق مجتمع
تعاوني من اصحابي الافكار
والمشاريع الناشئه
كون هذا المجتمع طبعا
المخيم العلوم كان واحد من اروع المجتمعات
اللي
صار بيناتنا نوع من
التلاحم التزاوج التشارك
هوايه افكار مالت منتجات نقدر انه نصنعها
بالمكان مالتنا هذا الاستثماري وانه
يضللون بالمظله مالتنا القانوني
والاداريه والاعفاءات والتسهيلات اللي
اخذت منها سنين
يعني اختصرنا الطريق لهم
المعجله الصناعيه انه عندي مكان كبير ضخم
همم
حاضر جاهز للتصنيع
للعمل الموافقات كلياتها الرخص والتسهيلات
الاعفاءات كلياتها موجوده ضمن هذا الغطاء
ال- ال- القانوني البنيه التحتيه موجوده
الكهرباء الميه الانترنت كرياتها موجوده
همم
الاستيراد مالت المواد الاوليه والخزن
هميا موجوده
هذا مجتمع
تكاملي يعني لما يكونون اكو هوايه عندنا
ورش
ومعامل معامل كرتون الخياطه
نوع من التعاون ماكو منتج اذا تريد تسوي
فد فد
منتج ذكي او خلينا نقول
شكرا
[موسيقى]
ايضا نوفر
التدريب التوجيه همم فريق متميز من
الخبراء
ابلكيشن او بال- بال- بالاي تي على مودي
يسوي لك التطبيقات مشترك بها التطبيقات
الحسابيه اداره المخازن اداره الانتاج
التسويق الالكتروني التسويق الرقمي همم
التطبيقات
واا الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
التمويل والتطوير طبعا السيستم يمشي
كلياتهم ان هذا تعاونيه صناعيه راح تشتغل
ب ب ب بسستم ال ال ال ال المشاركه الربحيه
هوايه افكار عندنا تقريبا فوق ال 85 همم
منتوج الافكار مالتها كليتها بين حديديه
الى
بلاستيكيه الى الى يعني عدد من الافكار
مالت المنتجات واحنا من الافكار السريعه
اللي ينطرحت وهي دكتور نورس
عالم البلاستيك عالم كبير وتقدر تسوي بيه
هوايه هوايه
جميله ولطيفه وذكيه واحد من هذه الامثله
اللطيفه هو هذا الكرسي اللي تشوفه قدامكم
اللي سميناه كرسي الارجيله وكل شيء
الارجيله حلو
لطيف مريح لونه لطيف جميل لون مالته
بهمين مكان مالت انه تحطه الكوب مالتك
وممكن انها تضيف عليه اضافه مالت الصينيه
طبعا اذا ضفت وياه ال ال ال ال ال الامور
ال- ال- ال- التكميليه الجزئيات التكميليه
التسويقيه الحلوه يعني مثلا كوشه حلوه
انت قاعد برا همم
التغليف الكرتوني
هنا اتذكروا هل هاي الصوره نجيه هنا هي
هاي تقريبا السلايد الاخير طولت ورايا
عليكم
فالمعجلات الصناعيه والتعاونيه تبدا اول
شيء بالفكره
الجروب
بعدين نجيء نشوف شلون رح نطبق هاي الفكره
دكتور نورس راح يصنع القالب مالت الكرسي
والتصميم مالتي هذا الطالب راح يجيب لي
اياه بالتعاونيه مال الطرح حطها بالمكابس
مالت البلاستيك راح نستعمل المواد الاوليه
اللي عندنا اياها
بيطلع عندنا الكرسي راح نجيء احنا نشوف
شلون شنو معايير الجوده مالت هذا المنتج
همم
لطيف شنو نضيف عليه اضافات اكو اشياء ممكن
نضيفها عاليه نغير شويه
بالتصميم مالتها بالشكل مالته
بعدين نمتي انه نسوي لك المنصه التسويقيه
مالته انه نعرف السوق
[موسيقى]
ينطلق المشروع الى السوق
وبصير نجاح مالت
منتوج طبعا
المعجله التعاونيه
راح يصير عندنا
المشروع الفتره مالت الانطلاق مالت
المشروع من كونه فكره الى الانطلاق فتره
ما تتجاوز اشهر قليله في حين اذا نورت
يريد انه يدي واحده بالمشروع يا استاذ
شركه
[موسيقى]
تاخذنا بين الاربع الى خمس ست سنوات هاي
الفتره طاقه مستهلكه
مصاريف الكبير
ويدخل بالدوامه مالت البيروقراطيه
احتماليه 90% انه يلغيها للفكره
بس المعجله هنا راح تخليك الحلم مالتك او
الفكره مالتك
خلال شهرين ثلاثه تنطلق بالسوق راح تقل
عندك التكاليف
بشكل كبير راح تستفاد من ال ال ال الشباب
اللي وياك بهذا المجتمع التعاون اللي هم
كلهم مواهب عاليه ومصنعين رحت استفاد من
الافكار مالتهم راح تستفاد من المراصه
الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
المشروع بده
ونتوقع الفرص النجاح مالته عاليه
واتامل انه راح تصير عندنا اكثر يعني احنا
حاليا هسه قاعد نشوف بدنا ندرس اكثر من 80
منتج اتمنى انه راح تكون اكثر واكثر
الرساله مالتي
الاخيره هي فمثل شعبي مصري كلش حلو وانا
احبه
هذا الشعار الشعار مالتنا واتمنى انه
القيادات اللي موجوده بالدوله
وبالمحافظه مالت البصره من من من من من
الاخوه المسؤولين المحافظ والمدراء
الدوائر انه يتعاونون وايانا يدخلون ويانا
بنفس المركز وشكرا
[تصفيق]